[MUSIC PLAYING]
JAMES DUKE: Hey, everyone.
My name's James Duke.
I'm in our Strategic
Cloud Engineering
group in our Professional
Services team.
I'm here with Shahid.
SHAHID MASUD: I'm Shahid.
I'm also a strategic cloud
engineer in the Google Cloud
Professional Services.
JAMES DUKE: I'm
going to talk to you
today a little bit about
the practical guide to--
what did we call it,
Practical Guide to Modernizing
Applications for Containers.
If folks have questions,
there is a Dory.
Please feel free to use it.
If you open your app, you
should have a link to it
from the Next app.
If you fire questions in today,
and we'll come back at the end
and address those questions.
We'll also take live questions.
We have a microphone.
So as we said, it's the
end of the day, right?
So we'll take a fairly--
it's going to be
a fairly casual--
SHAHID MASUD: Casual approach.
JAMES DUKE: --experience.
We're just going to have a chat.
It's like, you guys
are watching our chat,
and we're going to talk
you through this process
a little bit.
So what are our goals, Shahid?
SHAHID MASUD: So our goals
are really three things.
We want to understand what
modern applications look
like, what are some of the
terms or buzzwords you hear
associated with
modern applications,
like containers, microservices,
cloud native, and so on and so
forth, and why
they're important.
What do they mean
for your business?
Why would you want
to build applications
that are cloud native or that
run as containers, and so
on and so forth?
And then the real meat
of our session is in how.
How can you get your
application migrated over
so it uses some of those design
patterns that we'll discuss?
So those are really the three
main goals of this session.
JAMES DUKE: Yeah,
in the first two,
we'll level the
set a little bit.
We'll talk about the
definitions of some
of these things, the pros and
cons, and that kind of stuff.
And then we'll talk
about, what does a journey
to a modern application
look like today?
So let's start with what.
So, Shahid, what is a container?
SHAHID MASUD: So
yes, so containers,
you hear a lot of buzzwords
associated with containers,
that they're lightweight,
portable, fast,
and so on and so forth.
So let's look at, what
does this really mean?
So containers in themselves are
really about two technologies.
First, it's a way of packaging
your application and all
of its dependencies
into a single image.
And then the second
capability is the ability
to run that image in an
isolated set of processes.
So those are sort of
really the two main things
that containers provide you.
They let you package everything
that your application needs
into one single image,
and then provide you
a mechanism to run that
image in an isolated manner.
So that's really what this is.
And the key term
here is process.
So containers run as processes.
So just like when you start
something on your computer,
it starts a process
in the background.
It runs as a process.
Containers run the same way.
And containers are
a group of processes
that sort of work together
to provide some functionality
that you need.
JAMES DUKE: So who here has
built and deployed a container?
Show of hands.
OK, not bad.
Looks like about
half, I would say.
Who's used some kind of
container orchestration system,
Kubernetes, [INAUDIBLE]?
OK, about a third.
OK, that's good.
That's good.
That helps us with
the level setting
where we go through this.
So for those of you
who've deployed it,
you'll be very
familiar with this.
It gives you this
nice packaging.
You get the application.
You get the dependencies.
For those who are
less familiar with it,
this may be a new concept.
But the idea is that now I
only depend on an environment
to execute the container.
I don't have to care about
bringing in libraries.
bringing in dependencies,
because I've packaged them
all up into my container.
SHAHID MASUD: So
let's look at how
containers and some other ways
of running your application
sort of compare.
Some of you might be
familiar with this kind
of a diagram, which shows
what running applications
on a shared host looks
like, and that's basically,
the host provides the kernel and
it provides also the libraries
that your applications
need, and then
all of the applications that
are running on that host
share that kernel
and the libraries.
The challenge with
this kind of setup
is since the
libraries are shared,
you have to be really careful
which version of which
library is installed on that VM.
And for that reason,
a lot of the time,
people actually run one
application per host.
So they run one application.
They bring all the
dependencies that they need.
They bring it to that host.
Configure the host to be the
right kind of environment
for that application,
and then run it there.
JAMES DUKE: In many ways,
that's very convenient, right?
Because we now have a
kind of a logical grouping
of our applications.
The problem is, there's
kind of minimal boundaries
between those applications.
You can do some stuff
with sandboxing.
But generally speaking, in
this model, those applications,
they're all in a shared space.
And so I don't
have any security--
minimal security boundaries
between those things.
So that doesn't help me when
those applications should
be isolated from one another.
So if we go up the
stack a little bit,
the next thing we might
think about is VMs.
Well, why don't we take
those applications,
those dependencies, and then
we can fit multiple single host
application servers onto
one physical machine.
People talk about
bin packing, right?
We're now more effectively
using more of that machine's
resources, because we
have more things running
than we were able to before.
But the trade-off
here, of course,
is the libraries are not common,
and not just the libraries,
the kernel.
So now in a given host,
given physical machine,
I'm running multiple kernels.
And there is an overhead
for having done that.
Each kernel there will use
its own set of resources, CPU,
memory, and its boot
up time is a factor.
Every time I boot
a kernel, there
is a time penalty in doing so.
Especially [INAUDIBLE].
Modern kernels can
boot very quickly,
but there's still a penalty
there, because you still
have to do it there.
SHAHID MASUD: It can take a
matter of minutes for a VM
to boot up.
And it does provide a lot of
isolation, as we were saying,
but the cost is that
it's not very flexible.
If you need to
resize a VM, if you
need to give it
more resources, you
have to really essentially
rebuild that VM.
So that's where people went
to container technology.
Google was one of the
pioneers in that technology.
All of our workloads
internally run as containers,
predominantly.
So the containers provide
isolation within one host.
So instead of breaking up
that host into individual VMs,
we use some of the
mechanisms that
are available in the
kernel, in the Linux kernel,
to isolate a set of processes
from another set of processes.
And each of those
set is a container.
The great thing is that
they share the same kernel.
So once the host has booted
up, the kernel has loaded,
there's no more delay in
launching these containers.
And starting each
of these containers
is like running a process.
As soon as you type in a
command on your laptop,
for example, the application
comes up quickly.
It doesn't have to wait for
your machine to boot up.
So that's some of the
advantages of using containers.
JAMES DUKE: Yeah, it totally
removes that kernel boot time
that I was talking
about for the VMs.
It uses the same kernel.
The kernel's already running.
You just spin up
another process.
The reason we're kind of
doubling down on that is--
we'll talk in a minute
about what does cloud native
computing look like?
One of the most important
parts is scalability.
To me, when someone
says, I'm going
to build a cloud native
application, that means
it's going to be very scalable.
And VMs, they can
scale very well.
But imagine a scenario,
let's say, well,
like an unnamed company
who may or may not
have released a new
product this morning.
Imagine that your press release
generated a bunch of traffic
to your application.
You need to get a
response out very quickly.
If you have to wait
for kernels to boot up,
even if it is only
a minute or two,
that may result in a poor
experience for your users,
and that's especially concerning
if it's the first time they're
experiencing your system.
There's nothing worse than
sitting on a loading screen
the first time you ever
use a product to turn you
away from using it.
So with containers,
that's not a problem.
If you want to spin--
I mean, within reason, right?
It depends on how
many containers
you can fit on a given kernel.
But within reason, it
allows you to scale much,
much, much faster, because
you don't have that boot time
penalty.
SHAHID MASUD: One
drawback with containers
is that even though there's
less dependency on the host,
there's still a
dependency on the kernel.
Since the kernel
is shared, you have
to target a particular kernel.
But the good thing is,
these days, Linux kernel
is pretty standard.
So a lot of applications
target the Linux kernel
and can run as containers.
So with that in mind, let's
revisit some of those buzzwords
to see if you have a
better appreciation of what
that means.
So as we described it,
containers are lightweight.
And it's true, because they
don't have the overhead
of creating a full VM.
So virtual machine,
when you create one,
you have to provide the host
OS image on it, libraries,
and everything that you need
to run your application.
JAMES DUKE: And in a container,
you only put in what you need.
You're able to specify just
the bare minimum set of things
that the application needs
in order to do its job.
So you can end up
with containers
that are very, very, very
small from a actual disk space
perspective.
SHAHID MASUD: And
they are portable,
because you're bringing all
your dependencies with you.
So any libraries that you
need, you're bringing with you.
And all you need on
the host is really
the kernel and some runtime
that can run your container.
And those are pretty
standard these days,
the container run times,
and it's pretty easy
to install that on any host.
So that what makes your
containers portable.
And it's not just portable
from one VM to the other,
but it's also portable
across environments.
You can run the same
container on-prem
and on any sort of
cloud provider as well.
JAMES DUKE: Who--
SHAHID MASUD: Yeah, go ahead.
JAMES DUKE: Who caught
the keynote this morning?
Anyone see the keynote speech?
Yeah, so you saw our glorious
leaders talking about Anthos
and what Anthos
brings to the table.
So Anthos fundamentally builds
the construct of a container.
If you have a world
where you have
that hybrid,
multi-cloud environment,
once your application
is containerized,
moving it between those clouds
or between those environments
is very, very, very
straightforward.
So if you have a platform
where you can orchestrate
all of your security, your
networking, your monitoring
with your service
mission, everything,
and your configuration
management
all across those
different environments,
the question is
not, can I move it?
The question is, where
would be the optimal place
for that particular workload
or that particular application?
So when we say
portable, that's really
what we're talking about.
It's not moving it
from VM to the other.
It's much broader than that.
It's how do I put
this application
so it's as close to
my user as possible?
Or maybe it's something
as simple as this one
particular platform is more
cost-effective for the type
of workload that we're running.
Whatever it might
be, it gives you
the power to choose to run your
application wherever you want.
It's this old phrase, right?
Build once, run anyway.
SHAHID MASUD: Yeah.
Yeah.
And then they start fast.
So as we said, since there's
no overhead of starting a VM,
your containers
start as processes
would on an ordinary host.
So they boot-- they start--
I shouldn't say boot, but they
start in a matter of seconds.
And as long as your process
needs to start taking traffic,
that's all it takes
for it to do that.
So let's quickly demo one.
Just see how the
containers look running
from the host point of view as
well as the container itself.
So here I have a
Google Cloud VM.
And I'm going to run
a container image
that I've created and pushed to
one of the container registries
that we have.
So I'm going to
use the docker run
command to run this container.
And once I run
that, it has started
that container over here.
JAMES DUKE: Did you
see how fast he was?
SHAHID MASUD: Yeah.
JAMES DUKE: Did you
see how fast he was?
No kernel boot time.
SHAHID MASUD: So since I had
downloaded that image earlier
on this VM, it didn't even take
time to sort of start that.
So if I look at what
images are running,
this is the image
that's been running,
and it's been up 18 seconds
since I just started it.
And so let's look
at what the process
tree looks like on the VM.
So as you can see,
this is the VM.
So I'm looking at the host.
I'm looking at all the
processes that are running.
So this is everything
that's running on the host.
And part of that
tree, you will see,
is the containerd, which
is our container runtime,
and the nginx process that I
just started as a container.
So you'll see, this
is just one set
of processes within the
other processes that
are running on that host.
So there's nothing special
from the host point of view
for these processes, other
than it's just grouped together
and it has certain boundaries
associated with that.
Next what I can do is I can
look inside that container,
and I can attach myself
to that container,
and see what the
process tree looks
like from within that container.
So what I can do is I
can start another command
inside that container by
using the exec command.
So you see the command
prompt has changed here,
and now I am in the
context of that container.
This may look very
similar to a VM.
When you log into a VM,
you have a certain command
prompt and so on.
So if I look at the process
tree within the container,
you'll see it's a very
limited set of processes.
It doesn't even see
the containerd process,
that's the parent or
the container shim.
It only sees the nxginx
processes that I started.
And since I'm running
that ps command
and I just started
the [INAUDIBLE] shell,
you see that as well.
So from the container
point of view,
it has the whole host
available to itself.
It doesn't see any
other processes.
It cannot interact with
any other processes.
So that's where that
isolation comes in.
But from the point
of view of the host,
you can see pretty
much everything
that's running on the host.
So that's what
the difference is.
There's no magic here.
It's just processes that
have been sort of put
in the sandbox or a container.
SHAHID MASUD: In actual
fact, the Linux kernel
has no concept of a container.
It's a purely user
space construct.
So it's just built up of
processes, the sandbox,
from one another.
The reason we're
going into this detail
is because, as you can
see, Shahid right there
has-- do you have
root on this machine?
Do you have root here?
SHAHID MASUD: I might be.
I'm not sure.
JAMES DUKE: Shaid can look
inside all of that process
tree.
That is to say, if you
have sufficient permissions
on the host, then any containers
that are running in that
are potentially visible to you.
So when we talk about
security, and we
talk about how to
secure a cluster
and how to run
secure clusters, it's
not just about the containers.
It's not just about
the names, places.
It's also about the operating
system level access as well.
SHAHID MASUD: All right.
We can switch back
to the slides.
So let's look at some
of the other terminology
that we talked about.
So what are microservices?
Again, the things you see
associated with microservices
are that they're
loosely coupled,
they're sort of fine-grained,
they provide some minimal set
of functionality that's useful,
and they make you more agile,
and they should be
testable on their own,
and so on and so forth.
JAMES DUKE: Who's built
or deployed microservices?
OK.
About a quarter, I would say.
OK, OK.
So for those of you who you've
done it, what was the thinking?
What was the reasoning there?
Someone shout out.
Why go microservices?
AUDIENCE: Extract business
logic from your monolith.
JAMES DUKE: Extract business
Excellent.
Have we got one more?
AUDIENCE: Break up the monolith
to improve the scalabilitiy.
JAMES DUKE: Break
up the monolith
to improve scalability.
Also excellent.
All of these things,
they are absolutely
the value of the microservices.
So let's dig into
the two of those
and use those to
explain the buzzword.
So separate the business
logic from the monolith.
In a moment, we'll talk about
why you use these things.
But the short version of
that is these are tools.
And tools should be used
to solve business problems.
Technology just by
itself, while very cool--
and I'd say it's obviously
a passion of mine--
it doesn't solve
real-world problems
by being cool technology.
It solves real-world problems by
being applied in the right way
to real-world problems.
And so to the point of
extracting the business logic,
having everything
tied up in one thing--
it makes it very
difficult for you
to focus on the things that
are important for your business
or for your
customers' businesses,
because there's so
much other stuff
wrapped around it in this
giant, sprawling, in some cases
decades-old piece of software.
And it becomes very difficult
to say, OK, well, it's now 2019.
I need to do some stuff
because the market's changed.
My competitors have changed.
I have a new idea.
And it makes it very
difficult to do that when it
comes with all the other craft.
And the same is true of
the scaling piece, right?
If I have a monolith,
and I suddenly
have the success-disaster
scenario I described earlier,
I get 100 or 1,000
decks' traffic
that I do on a usual
basis, to scale
that, I have to either absorb
it in the existing monolith
or recreate instances
of the monolith
and manage traffic
between those instances.
And that is a very, very-- well,
can be a very, very painful
thing to do, because often
those monoliths are not
designed to spin up quickly.
They have a bunch
of dependencies.
In some cases, they run
on specific hardware.
There's all sorts of reasons why
that can become very difficult.
But if you break each
part of that monolith out
into its own
microservice, now I can
scale each one of those
services independently.
I can modify and update
each one of those
independently to change
the business logic,
to add new features.
In summary, it
makes us more agile,
because it allows us to respond
to changing market conditions
and, indeed, changing
technology conditions as well.
SHAHID MASUD: And
testing-- the same thing.
Once you have a smaller
piece of functionality
that you have to
test, your releases
are quicker because
you don't have
to worry about testing
all the features
that you've built into
this big monolith.
So I hope with these you have
a better understanding of why
the industry has been moving
towards microservices.
Next, let's look at
the cloud native.
So cloud native means
built for the cloud
or sort of born in the
cloud, if you will.
And typically, you
hear that if you
want to build for the cloud,
you have to use containers.
You have to be a
microservices architecture.
And what it will give
you is quicker releases
and scalability and all that.
Some of these reasons
we saw earlier.
When we looked at
containers, you
saw that containers are
easy to sort of deploy
from one place to the other.
You don't have to prepare
the infrastructure as much
to run your container because
you're bringing all the bits
that you need with you.
So you're building the bits.
And the infrastructure
is just providing
the compute and other
resources that you need.
JAMES DUKE: But it is important
to note the three things are
different, right?
A containerized application
is not necessarily
the same as a
microservices architecture.
They often go hand in hand.
But it's not necessarily true.
And you could do
both of those things
and still not be cloud native.
Or you could be cloud native
and do neither of those things.
The three are not
necessarily the same.
We do typically see
them coming together.
But certainly, from what
we've seen with our customers
and in the broader IT
and computing industry,
we have seen typically a
cloud-native application
display as a microservices
architecture.
And it's usually
containerized, especially when
we look at something
like Anthos,
all right, which naturally leads
towards a containerized and
microservices model.
And all of the three
things together
is where we kind of see the
future of our field going.
SHAHID MASUD: Yeah.
JAMES DUKE: So that's what.
Now why.
So we touched on
this a little bit.
Shahid, why should
we use containers?
SHAHID MASUD: So I see
containers, and microservices,
and all these as
enabling technologies.
So they do not bring necessarily
benefit in themselves.
They enable you to sort
of reap the benefits
of the modern infrastructure
that's available in the cloud.
So that's how you
should think about it.
This is not the end, in itself.
It's a means to an end.
And you get all of the
benefits that we talked about
that you get from containers.
You get the portability,
you know, the scaling up
and down-- fast scaling up and
down and portability and all
that-- with that.
And it opens up a lot
of options for you.
You can run the same
container in a VM.
You can run it in a
platform, like Kubernetes.
Or you can run it even in
serverless platforms like Cloud
Run and so on.
And similarly,
microservices and containers
together provide some of the
benefits that we talked about.
You can scale up your
application quicker.
But again, your application
has to be built in such a way
still that it can
be scaled up easily.
And we'll see that
when we look at how,
as to how to think about
that when you're designing
your application, or
as you're converting
your monolith into
a microservices
or a modern architecture.
JAMES DUKE: We do want to
talk a little bit about what
the options are for where
we can run these containers.
SHAHID MASUD: Yeah.
And quicker release
cycles are basically
since it's not a big application
that you're releasing,
your microservices are smaller.
So it's easier to
manage the releases.
If you think about it, when
you start off a project,
it's easy to sort of
iterate on the code.
As the code base grows bigger,
than it becomes challenging.
So keeping it in microservices
forces you sort of
to keep that code base smaller,
as you're separating out
your business logic
into individual repos
and individual release cycles.
So what that gives
you is that, once you
have the image, once you've
built the image the right way,
you can now run it in
many different types
of infrastructure.
And here's some
examples, with just once
you've built your image--
just hello-world
in this example--
with one command,
you can run it.
You can pick the
runtime that you want.
And you can deploy the same
image in any of these products
that Google Cloud
Platform offers.
JAMES DUKE: Yeah, so
very simple, right?
Four different commands.
You have the same
container running
in four different
infrastructures, or four
different platforms,
should I say.
And so when we talk
about portability, like,
this is what it looks
like in practice, right?
Now, in reality this is a little
bit of a trite example, right,
because most people aren't
pushing a single container
with a single command.
More than likely, it
would be in some kind
of orchestration platform.
But the same thing holds
true across the different
orchestration platforms, too.
SHAHID MASUD: Yeah, so
here, you can look at--
you can't just at
random pick one day--
oh, I'm going to run my app
in App Engine or Cloud Run.
JAMES DUKE: Well, you could.
SHAHID MASUD: Yeah, you could.
JAMES DUKE: I wouldn't
recommend that.
But you could.
SHAHID MASUD: You can once
you have the container built.
But here's some guidance on how
you can pick the right runtime.
And the way to look at it
is it's sort of a continuum.
On one end, you have
pure infrastructure
that gives you a lot of
flexibility of how you want
to manage that infrastructure.
For example, VMs--
you can pick the image
that you want to
deploy on your VM.
You can configure it
the way you want to.
You can put libraries
that you want to on it,
and then you can run
your container on it.
And that's one option.
And what you're getting
is a lot of control.
What you're giving up
is, or what you're, I
guess, signing up
for, I should say,
is now you have to
maintain that VM.
Since you created
a custom VM, you
have to make sure that any
updates that are needed
are applied to that.
And as you move in the
stack to the right,
you start giving
up that control.
You're letting the platform
or your cloud-hosting provider
take on some of those
responsibilities
of operational aspects
of your infrastructure.
And you're focusing more and
more on just your workload.
But your workload has
to conform to sort
of the APIs or standards
that that platform expects
it to have.
So that's the trade-off
involved in moving
from left to the right of this.
And eventually, sort of
the new sort of nirvana
is serverless, where
you're not worried about
your infrastructure at all.
And you're letting
your cloud provider
provide the infrastructure for
you based on your workload.
And all you're
providing is, again,
your image, which is exactly
the bit that you need,
the software that you
need, and nothing extra.
And you're letting your hosting
provider provide the underlying
infrastructure for you.
JAMES DUKE: Absolutely.
OK, we've teased it enough.
We've done all the background,
done the level setting.
Let's jump into how we might
actually do this, right,
because it seems
like a daunting task.
You're faced with
a giant monolith.
Like I said, it
could be decades old.
It's a daunting,
daunting task to take on
and say, OK, I want to
actually change this.
Where do I start?
So we've kind of--
well, I mean, we didn't
come up with this approach.
It's been around for a while.
But we wanted to share
with you some things
today that we've
found to be effective
when we've done this
with our own customers,
and as a suggestion for
ways that you folks could
do the same.
So first step-- you need a list.
You need to know
what do you have?
What does it look like?
What is it running?
What does it do?
What technologies
does it involve?
What are its dependencies?
And more to the point,
what group is it in?
So classifying it on the
basis of a number of things.
So we kind of came up with
these three groups, right?
SHAHID MASUD: Yeah.
JAMES DUKE: So we start off
with stateless applications.
As you might imagine,
stateless applications
tend to be the easiest
group to deal with.
And so we tend to deal with them
first, things like web front
ends, existing services--
maybe they're micro,
maybe they're not--
and existing APIs that
just take in data,
transform, and send
out that data, anything
that has no statement,
anything that takes a request,
gives a response,
but doesn't rely
on some kind of
underlying state.
Group all those
together, and they
tend to be our first movers.
And that tends to be
our first place to go.
Web front ends in
particular seem
to be a very popular approach.
Part of the reason for this
is you want this first mover
to be non-trivial.
You don't necessarily want it
to be the number one revenue
generator for the business
because the first time you
do this, there's a bit
of a learning curve.
But you do want it to be
something that's meaningful
and that has some kind
of real-world use,
because if you just start
with a hello-world application
that nobody uses, it doesn't
really prove anything out.
So often we'll find
that web front ends,
whilst they are in the
critical path for a lot of user
journeys, they tend not to be--
well, hopefully-- they tend
not to be too complicated
and are stateless, usually,
and so lend themselves
very well to this first group.
SHAHID MASUD: Yeah.
JAMES DUKE: Then the second
group, temporary state.
What do we mean by
temporary state, Shahid?
SHAHID MASUD: So
temporary state is
something where an
application, when it starts up,
it starts building up its state.
It doesn't sort of persist
that state between startups.
And a typical example is
a caching application--
Redis or memcache or
anything like that.
When it starts up, it
doesn't have any state.
But as people put items in that
cache, it starts building up.
And if you had to restart that,
it's not a catastrophic event.
You could restart it.
But you'll suffer some
loss in response time.
Or there might be
some errors that you
might see as it's restarting.
Similarly, applications that
sort of take on different role
once they start up.
For example, you could
have a master and a slave.
When they start up,
they are all the same.
But then they somehow
coordinate to pick one master--
things like that.
Redis has that.
And there are other
examples of that as well.
So this is sort of the second
group that we've come up with.
And we're calling
it temporary state,
because again, that state is
not persisted across restarts.
It's something that it
acquires as it's running.
So these can be great second
movers, because again, once you
have the knowledge of what does
it take to run applications
as containers in a more
dynamic environment,
you are ready to take on the
challenging of how to build
that state dynamically.
How can you elect a
master when the existing
master dies without someone
manually intervening and so on?
Or how can you build up maybe
the cache from other replicas
and sort of redistribute
cache as one of the replicas
dies or something like that?
So that's why this is our second
group that you should look at.
JAMES DUKE: And then
thirdly and finally,
stateful applications--
databases,
file servers, and raw storage.
It's not impossible-- in
fact, it's very doable--
to move stateful applications
into a containerized or
microservices architecture.
But it's more complicated
than the prior ones.
Typically, many, especially
more legacy databases,
aren't necessarily set
up to just add more nodes
to get more capacity, right?
They have a concept
of master and slave
but in a very different way.
They're often not dynamically
deciding and voting
and promoting new masters.
Some do, but many don't.
And so these really--
these probably want
to be the last thing
that you would consider, largely
because they benefit the least.
They benefit the least from
migrating to this new paradigm.
And they have the least amount
of benefit for most complexity
to actually change them as well.
SHAHID MASUD: And
how many of you
have tried scaling MySQL
database, for example?
You can't just add
a replica and expect
it to work out of the box.
So it requires some sort of
manual design and decisions
that you have to do
that you can't just
say, oh, I need
another MySQL instance,
and just add it there,
and go from there.
So that's why these are more
difficult to containerize.
And the benefit
isn't as much there,
because you won't be scaling
these up and down dynamically
to begin with.
JAMES DUKE: So first
step, list and group.
Second step, containerize
parts of the application.
In most cases, you probably
don't want to go-- well,
it's possible to go
to a big-bang approach
to all of this and say,
hey, you know what?
We're going to take
our whole company out
of our regular release schedule
for six weeks or three weeks.
And we're going to go, like,
just do the whole thing.
We're going to take
the whole application,
wrap it up in containers,
and release it out.
Lovely in practice.
Very, very, very difficult to
do in-- sorry, lovely in theory.
Very, very difficult
to do in practice.
In practice, in most cases,
most real-world scenarios,
you'll want to do this
one step at a time.
So once you have your
list, and your groupings,
and your priorities,
then it becomes
about finding parts
of that application
to move to those
containers first.
SHAHID MASUD: All right.
JAMES DUKE: So some examples.
The most basic example of all
of this is take the monolith,
and put it into a
container, right?
It's the fastest way.
And technically, you now have a
containerized workload, right?
Check the box.
Yes, I can do containers.
It's quick to deploy
and actually can
be automated, which we'll
come to in a second.
This allows you to
prove out the concept.
It allows you to get
comfortable with the technology
and, depending on the
nature of the monolith,
may allow some scaling that
wasn't possible before.
But you don't really
get the full benefit.
Having said that, it can be
a very worthwhile exercise,
both from a learning
perspective,
but also from a "need to
move right now" perspective.
And, you know, the reality
is many times in the projects
that we've seen, there is some
kind of compelling event--
Black Friday, Cyber Monday,
a holiday, a sports event,
or even something as mundane as
a data center lease expiring.
I have to get out my
data center by April 29,
or whatever it might be.
SHAHID MASUD: So this is part of
the lift-and-shift sort of kind
of migration, where you're
lifting the application,
just containerizing
it, and shifting it
as a container to the cloud.
And there are ways to
do this automatically.
In fact, if you saw the
keynote this morning,
you saw an example of an
app being migrated from a VM
into Kubernetes Engine
running as containers.
So there's Anthos
Migrate, which helps
you do this automatically.
So you can do it
manually as well.
But there are instances
where you can just
use the automated
service like Anthos
to do it for you as well.
So again, this can be a
good start to your journey.
JAMES DUKE: So the
next approach would
be, OK, so let's
think about how we
would migrate some parts of a
three-tier application, right?
So in many cases, the
way you would do this,
you would put this behind
a load balancer, right?
Put a load-balancer
in front of--
you may already have one.
But put one behind the
Google Cloud Load Balancer.
And then we can look at the app
front end and the app backend.
Remember, we said these are the
pieces that don't necessarily
store state.
Maybe the backend might be one
of our semistate applications.
The front end would
typically be no state.
And then what we can do is
wrap those up in containers.
And now we can scale
those tiers individually.
So if we have that
success-disaster scenario,
I can rapidly scale
up my front end
to handle those requests
without necessarily having to do
the same scaling to my backend.
Now, of course, you may
end up with contention
to the database
in that scenario.
But at least it allows you to
respond-- at the very least,
allows you to respond with
a, we're working on it,
we'll get back to you,
instead of just returning
a 404 or a 503.
SHAHID MASUD: One
thing to clarify
is that red box does not
show one container boundary.
The white boxes are
really containers.
So you want to run the
front end separately
in a separate container
and the backend separately.
And this is a nice transition
from a monolith as well.
This could be the first step
at breaking up a monolith.
Typically, sort of the
front end part of a monolith
is easy to break up.
So you can start with that.
And you can separate
that out, modernize
it using some new
technology, and leave
the rest of the monolith
running as the backend
for that front end.
So this could be a good
starting point on your journey.
JAMES DUKE: But we're still
not all the way there, right?
We still don't get
all the benefits.
So what can we go to next
where we get a little bit more
of the benefits we
were talking about?
So we can start to think about
a transitional microservices
architecture.
We're still kind of mostly
in a monolith mode here.
But we're kind of dipping our
toes in the water a little bit.
We're going to say, well, OK,
one small part of that monolith
we're going to break out and
build into a separate service.
And in some cases, this might
actually be completely new
functionality.
We've actually seen
both work, where
we've had customers
that have built
a new function or a new feature
as a new microservice and left
everything else in the monolith.
We've also seen folks
who've said, well, actually
you know what?
This one particular
part of my monolith,
I can carve that
out, and recreate
that same functionality,
that same feature,
in a separate service.
Now, likely that means
you have dead code, right?
There's probably code left
in that legacy backend
that now no longer operates.
And that introduces
some problems, right?
You may have code duplication.
So maybe some technical deck to
remove that out later in time.
It may be possible to
remove it there and then.
That's really very dependent
on the particular application
that we're working with.
But the basic principle goes
take a piece out, move it
over there.
And now that piece
can scale very easily,
and we don't have to really
affect the existing monolith.
There's very little
appetite for changing
the monolith in a lot of
the customers we work with,
especially things that are
in a more regulated industry
or in a more traditional
enterprise-type space, where
they don't really want to touch
it because it has been running
that way for 10
years, and they're
very nervous about
changes breaking it.
So when we do it
like this, we don't
have to touch that monolith.
We can leave it well alone,
so there's very little risk
to the business.
SHAHID MASUD: Yeah.
And this is a great
way of reducing risk
as you're migrating,
because taking
small steps, making small
changes, reduces your risk.
You don't have to worry
about making a big change
and upsetting something
that you didn't even
know might go wrong when
you start peeling things.
The other thing is, when
you take small steps,
it's easier to sort of estimate
what you would need to do.
And you can apply your
learnings to the next steps
that you will take as well.
So the first time you're
building a microservice,
you might be learning a lot.
And you can apply
those learnings
as you build more and
more microservices.
If you start with
four or five, you'll
be repeating the same
mistakes across four or five
work streams that
you could avoid
by doing one change at a time.
JAMES DUKE: So
then the next step
is let's add an API gateway.
And now the API gateway
becomes the arbiter
of where all traffic goes.
So any time a request comes in--
it can come directly from the
load balancer in some cases,
or it can come from the
application front end--
now, the API gateway
decides where traffic goes.
So very minimal change as well.
No changes required
to the front end,
except pointing at a different
IP address or service name.
And now the API gateway
gets to decide, OK,
which backend do I need
to send this request to?
Is this something that
I need to send over
to the backend, the legacy
backend, the monolith,
or is this something
that I can send
to one of these fancy new
microservices that we have?
And this is particularly
powerful because--
think about this.
As you add service B,
C, D, E, and so on,
now the only piece
that has to change
to support those new
services is the API gateway.
So it becomes a single
point of configuration
that's basically
routing your traffic
from monolith or microservice.
SHAHID MASUD: So it gives
you that flexibility
of where to send that traffic.
And it hides that detail of
what microservices you actually
have running behind the
scenes from your clients,
from the consumers
of those services.
So they don't have to
know that now you've
migrated service B
or C over and you're
no longer calling the monolith.
It can also provide
some added benefits.
For example, if you
wanted to add TLS, or SSL,
or this [INAUDIBLE],,
like you wanted to secure
the communication, the
API gateway can typically,
you can add that functionality
very easily using the API
gateway--
API gateway support
providing TLS.
It can also provide
rate limiting.
Or it can have other
features, like if it detects
some failures and stuff, it
can provide sort of circuit
breaking and other things.
So depending on the API
gateway of your choice,
it can add a lot of features
to all your services
with very little cost.
All of these features are
built into the API gateway
that you might have.
So you get all those
benefits with that.
JAMES DUKE: So
then finally, there
is the true microservices--
the end goal
that we've been
shooting for all along.
You'll see that the API gateway
is still a key component.
Eventually, we could get to a
place where we don't need that.
You can have something like
a service mesh or Vistio
or something like that to
control all the communications.
But we still consider it a
true microservices place,
even though we have the
API gateway involved.
And at this point,
we've basically
taken the previous one
and started spinning up
these extra services, right?
Service B, service-- if you have
a service, B through Service N.
And now we've got
all that good stuff--
everything we
talked about in why
microservices and
containerization and cloud
native design gets--
why it gets our business.
We can scale every
service individually.
Each one has its own lifecycle.
So we've seen
customers who have gone
from releasing once a quarter
to releasing 60 or 100 times
a day, because now
they can release small,
small things very,
very, very, very quickly
in that pace of
innovation, because it
improves so much, just by
moving to this type of model.
The downside, of course--
it's harder to manage.
SHAHID MASUD: Yes.
JAMES DUKE: Right?
Or different to manage, because
if you're a company that
is used to dealing
with a monolith,
it requires a
change of thinking,
because now I've got
multiple services
with multiple teams that are
responsible for maintaining
those services.
I probably need to
create some kind
of centralized CICD system,
some kind of configuration
management platform, all
these kind of overheads
which go into orchestrating
all of these microservices.
But when this happens, when you
get to this beautiful state,
because you have so
much agility and ability
to innovate in the
application development teams,
the company or the business
is able to spend so much more
of its resources on the thing
that actually makes money,
because running the
perfect Kubernetes cluster
doesn't make money.
Well, I mean, maybe for Google,
but not for most customers,
whereas being able to innovate
and being agile and respond
to the market-- that's where
the true business value is.
And this is the
way you get there.
Now, does anybody
recognize that pattern?
Anyone know what it's called?
I wish I'd made this
up, but I didn't.
This is the Strangler pattern.
So this is-- yeah,
[CHUCKLES] sounds
a bit macabre, doesn't it?
It actually comes
from a tree analogy.
And so the principle
goes like this.
If you have a big, old,
well-established tree--
we're in California.
So let's call it a Redwood.
You have a big Redwood tree,
which represents the monolith.
And then you have a
bunch of vines growing up
around that tree.
As those vines become more
and more mature and stronger
and stronger and
hardier and hardier,
there comes a point in
time at which they are now
providing more structural
integrity than the tree
around which they are growing.
If that tree dies and rots
away, the structure remains.
And that's basically what
we're trying to do here.
We are trying to
build microservices
around the monoliths
such that we've
made the monolith obsolete.
And we can shut it
down, and remove it,
and throw it away, and never
shed a tear for it ever again.
And so that's the basic premise
of the Strangler pattern.
And it gives you
that flexibility.
And it gives you a gradual
or partial path forward,
so you don't have to do
everything in one go.
SHAHID MASUD: Yeah.
And as we mentioned, your
organizational processes
would need to change,
as well, as you
move from one type of
architecture to the other.
CICD is one thing we mentioned.
Just increasing
developer velocity
will have its own challenges.
When you have multiple
releases going out,
imagine doing tens of releases
instead of one release
a quarter or whatever
you're used to.
So this allows you to
gradually change your posture
from a traditional
organization to a more
agile microservices-based
organization as well,
with less risk.
JAMES DUKE: All right,
finally, profit.
At the end of the day, that's
what business is all about,
right?
Three easy steps-- categorize,
migrate small parts,
build up to the final
thing, and profit.
All right, so some
useful resources.
We are very blessed here to
have a wonderful set of labs.
Please go find the
hands-on lab session.
You've got all sorts
of fancy machinery
there to go try out
these particular labs.
We highly recommend the GKE
Best Practices Qwiklabs Quest.
Shahid and the team put a lot
of work into building those out.
And they kind of
guide you through some
of these best practices
we've talked about here.
SHAHID MASUD: Yeah,
And they guide you.
They are labs that
start from just building
your first container
and deploying it,
to all the way to
hardening those containers,
adding security or
cluster, as well as going
all the way to maybe deploying
a service mesh, and so on and so
forth.
So you can pick the expertise
level that you have.
And you can find a Quest or lab
related to that expertise level
and go from there.
JAMES DUKE: We also have a bunch
of open-source code samples
and templates.
The URL is there.
Please check them out.
There are about nearly
20 repos now, I think,
which show essentially how you
would do this in production.
And they are templates that
you can grab, copy, iterate on,
and deploy into your
environment to get
you started very, very quickly
with some of these things.
SHAHID MASUD: Yeah, and
these are open-source.
That link will take you
to a bunch of GitHub repos
that you're free to use.
They're under Apache
license and open-sourced.
[MUSIC PLAYING]